[Music]
the following statements constitute a
non-sequitur i am richer than you are
therefore i am superior to you or i am
more eloquent than you are therefore i
am superior to you but the following
conclusions are better i am richer than
you are therefore my property is
superior to yours or i am more eloquent
than you are therefore my elocution is
superior to yours but you are neither
property nor allocution
in chapter 44 epictetus is telling us
about a fallacy
that people often engage in and we do
ourselves so he gives examples of this
i am richer than you are therefore i am
superior to you or i am more eloquent
than you are therefore i am superior to
you and we sometimes say these sorts of
things or think them to ourselves
we certainly do these kinds of
comparisons with respect to other people
we may do it in a much more complex way
where we look at where we fall into a
certain kind of hierarchy or scale and
where other people fall
and all of that is essentially along the
same lines notice too that it can work
the other way around where we say i have
less money than you therefore i am
inferior to you we can even go so far
as to try to turn the lack of money or
resources or whatever we want into
something that's a sign of superiority
and say i have less money than you
therefore i am superior to you because
we all know rich people are jerks or you
know uh they're they're they're part of
the one percent or they can't be trusted
or any of those sorts of things all of
these inferences according to epictetus
are
essentially fallacious that is they are
bad arguments that have a determinate
structure we can identify them fairly
well
we can only do this when we bring them
out and recognize them
as kinds of arguments rather than being
facts about the world as people often
like to present them or as people
internalize them and then sort of act on
them without thinking them through
without ever making them explicit
it's only when we think it through that
we can see that there's no there's no
inherent connection between these and
that's what he points out here he says
the following conclusions are better
here's what you can actually draw as a
conclusion from i'm richer than you
i'm richer than you
so therefore my property is superior to
yours
he's not saying that uh
everything is superior he's saying that
if you're richer you have more money or
you have a nice house or you uh have a
place that you don't have to you know
have such a bad commute or
you know the roof isn't falling in or
whatever it is that you want i've got
nice nice clothes so therefore
i can dress better than you okay that's
fine right
i have this skill or this skill or this
skill therefore in that matter i am
superior to you
probably we can reverse it around and
say there's many other people who are
better at that and i'm also inferior in
that respect to those people
now notice what he's doing there he's
saying
yes there is a greater and lesser with
respect to riches with respect to
eloquence lexus in this with respect to
medical expertise with respect to how
much muscle you've got or anything along
these lines you know we could pick silly
things like i've got one chalkboard you
probably don't have a chalkboard in
respective chalkboards i'm superior to
you
now if having a chalkboard is a bad
thing then you are superior to me but
notice we've confined it to just that
thing
and that's what epictetus thinks that we
need to do
if we want to maintain a proper
perspective and not get suckered in
to thinking that these things like
riches or the attractiveness of our body
or the kinds of clothes that we wear or
the positions that people give us really
tell us anything fundamental about value
of human persons
notice what he says to bring this to a
close
you
are neither property nor elocution
you have property but you are not your
property
we we fall into this quite easily we
make mistakes in identifying ourselves
with the things that we have or even the
things that we
aspire to you know we join a program and
we think that because we're doing that
that somehow says something
significative about us as a person as
the value that we have as a person
so you know you're you join a gym and
you you even
go and exercise you don't just you know
subscribe to the gym and never go you go
and exercise that's great healthy for
your body maybe you meet some nice
people there uh provided you don't get
too competitive with everybody else
it's probably a good thing overall
but that's only about the gym that's
only about physical exercise or
networking that's not about you
as who you are
in your core although of course you
could use the gym as an opportunity to
say practice stoicism to
you know do the sorts of things that a
stoic would do to use things properly
like your body like the weights like
your membership
but it's not you
you
are fundamentally
your faculty of choice
you are fundamentally what it is that
you bring into every situation your
property can disappear
any skill that you learn that can
disappear it's so easy for us
to identify ourselves with things that
the stoics would consider either to be
external to us entirely like you know a
tie
or a youtube presence or
you know having a chalkboard
or to identify ourselves with the roles
that we have you know i am this kind of
worker i'm this kind of guy i have this
uh title
and that's what i am epic theta says no
no that's not what you are so if
somebody has a better title than you
great they've got a better title than
you if you've got a better title than
them great that's fine but don't think
that you're better than them as a person
or that they're better than you as a
person and if they try that line now you
know exactly how to deconstruct that
kind of argument
somebody is hasty about bathing do not
say that he bathes badly but that he is
hasty about bathing
somebody drinks a great deal of wine do
not say that he drinks badly but that he
drinks a good deal
for until you have decided what judgment
prompts him how do you know what he is
doing is bad and thus the final result
will not be that you receive convincing
sense impressions of some things but
give your assent to others
chapter 45 contains a very useful
reminder about the heast with which we
judge other people or the ways in which
we as we say jump to conclusions
something that we want to avoid if we
want to make progress on the the stoic
path to freedom tranquility and
happiness
so notice the two examples that he gives
these are examples that i think we can
still relate to today we we might think
of many other similar examples he says
somebody is hasty
about bathing they they bathe too
quickly right um let's extend this to
personal hygiene in general they're too
quick to get in and out of the shower
when they shave perhaps they don't do a
very good job
their hair is is usually a mess
when they tie their tie they don't
really pay attention to what they're
doing
that's fine now how are we going to
judge that what are we going to say
about it you know notice too that the
judgment lies in how we describe it to
ourselves
and the judgment is coming to us
as
something that we can assent to it's
it's an appearance
and then we go out to meet the
appearance with our judgment
so
we can say to ourselves that person
bathes hastily so they bathe badly right
they're not actually doing the job right
they're not doing things the way a
person ought to
or we can just say okay all i really
know is that they they're awfully quick
in the bathroom they don't seem to spend
an awful lot of time on personal hygiene
i'm not quite sure how one gets clean in
that short of a time but
i'll just leave it at that
instead of saying they're doing a
terrible job
instead of saying they don't bathe you
know the way a person should
we just leave it at that observation
the other one that he has as an example
is a person drinks a great deal of wine
say that they drink a great deal be
factual about it don't say that they
drink badly or that they you know make
up you know things like well they're a
stinking drunk you know don't jump to
conclusions about the evidence that you
have in front of you
and you're going to be a lot better off
when it comes to judging other people
we you know we can understand this in
our own cases because we want people to
like you know pay attention to the whole
person before they make snap judgments
about us although we fear that they're
going to make that and so there's some
things often that we we do like you know
dressing in certain ways or speaking in
certain ways not speaking in other ways
bringing up certain topics not bringing
up other topics
comporting ourselves in different ways
and so you know if we're worried about
other people doing this to us why are we
doing it to them
and it's not just a matter of what you
might call fairness about judgment or
assumptions or perceptions
there's something more here at stake
he says until you've decided what
judgment
prompts this person
to do what they're doing
the the dogma the opinion the idea that
they have the perspective that they have
until you know as we say what's going on
in their head
or until we know as we sometimes say
what makes that person tick
we don't know why they're doing things
the way they are and often that why
turns out to be more important than the
what about their doing
somebody might be
bathing very quickly
and spending relatively little time on
personal hygiene
because they're living in a dorm with a
lot of other people and they're very
nervous about their body and about other
people seeing them and so they want to
spend as little time as possible in a
common area where other people see them
walking around in a towel
it could be that they
don't like the feel of water on their
body it could be that they
said i want to stink as much as possible
so i'm going to spend as little time
on personal hygiene as possible these
are all live possibilities right and we
can't automatically assume that well
it's this motivation rather than this
motivation
we don't know
until we do a few things we could ask
the person of course they could lie to
us but oftentimes people are willing to
tell us some things and even when they
lie sometimes they reveal things to us
we can pay attention to them over time
see how they behave in similar
situations piece together kind of a
mosaic
that tells us about you know how that
person is motivated we can ask other
people if they know what's going on with
this person there's a lot of different
ways in which we can we can get better
information
but like he says
until you've decided what judgment is
prompting him
how do you know what he is doing is
actually
bad
how do you know if it's being badly done
cacos in in the greek
it might be that the person just uh
doesn't know what they're doing
it could be that they were brought up
that way and they think that's a good
way to behave
all of these are things that require us
to invest a bit of time and attention
before
engaging in judgment
now
what he says here
in the last part of this chapter
actually brings in some technical terms
that the stoics used and so i want to
mention a few things about that he says
the final result will not be that you
receive convincing sense impressions of
some things but give your ascent to
others
so what does all that mean okay so the
convincing sense impressions are the
fantasias cataleptic case allepticos
this was a criteria that the stoics used
in their epistemology and their views
about what we could rely on in their
views about what counted as knowledge
the stoics thought that
at a certain point we reach the bedrock
we reach the reality of what's going on
there are appearances right fantasia
but some of the fontasia really do show
us the way things truly are
those are the ones that we can trust in
those are the catalepticos the
cateleptic case in in this case right
and
we don't know
whether we've reached that bedrock or
not if we're making decisions like that
about how people are behaving so to take
the bathing example again
until we actually understand the
motivation of the person
and that doesn't necessarily take you
know spending years with them or even
days we could ask them what their what
their motivation is
and if we if we think that we've reached
the bedrock of that where there's no
further explanation
now we can make a determination now we
we have a good ground for that sort of
thing we're not going to be off base
when we do it
what he also talks about here
uh is is giving a scent
sun catastro
[Music]
you know you've got two different
prepositions sun and kata and then
tithiside is coming from the the verb
which means to place or or to set so
think of these all together as you know
something is presents itself and we
we're not sure whether it's
that way or not but we give a sent to it
we say okay i i'm gonna go along with
this
what what epictetus is saying here is if
you actually do follow this guideline
about not making judgments about whether
something is done well or done poorly
but just describe things the way they
are until you've got more information
and can piece together a coherent
picture
you're not going to be having some
things that you really can rely on and
other things that you're just assenting
to but probably are wrong about it's not
going to be a mishmash or a mixture of
these things you're actually going to
arrive at the point where you have all
of these things that are based on on
reality and you can be sure about them
so this is actually good advice in how
to deal with other people it's also
going to have the beneficial
side effect of probably not
causing a lot of conflicts with other
people as you tell them you know hey
you're behaving like a jerk you're
acting badly
when you've made a judgment that they're
doing so without actually knowing what
what's going on with them it may be that
they do in fact feel they're acting
badly
but it may be that they think that
they're doing the most rational thing in
the world so you want to find out
why they're behaving the way that they
are
on no occasion call yourself a
philosopher and do not for the most part
talk among laymen about your philosophic
principles but do what follows from your
principles
for example at a banquet do not say how
people ought to eat but eat as a man
ought for remember how socrates had so
completely eliminated the thought of
ostentation that people came to him when
they wanted him to introduce them to
philosophers and he used to bring them
along so well did he submit to being
overlooked
and if talk about some philosophic
principle arises among laymen keep
silence for the most part for there is a
great danger that you will spew up
immediately what you have not digested
so when a man tells you that you know
nothing and you like socrates are not
hurt then rest assured that you are
making a beginning with the business you
have undertaken
for sheep too do not bring their father
to the shepherds and show how much
they've eaten but they digest their food
within them and on the outside produce
wool and milk and so do you therefore
make no display to the layman of your
philosophical principles but let them
see the results which come from these
principles when digested
chapter 46 contains some really
excellent advice for those of us who are
engaged in studying philosophy you know
in particular stoic philosophy which is
a practical philosophy
how should we behave
should we tell people that we're
philosophers should we tell people that
we're studying philosophy
or should we do something different so
epictetus says
don't call yourself a philosopher
there's plenty of people out there doing
that
all you got to do is you know type in
google search i am a philosopher you'll
see all sorts of people who are making
those sorts of statements
so he says do not for the most part talk
among laymen that is people who are not
on the way in philosophy people who are
not studying philosophy people who are
not interested in philosophy but perhaps
could be don't talk to them
about your
philosophical principles or in the greek
uh tone
the things that you contemplate the
things that you think through
why not
why should you avoid this are you are
you being
deceptive in doing so
no
you're actually trying to be more more
truthful in certain respects
he says
do what follows from your principles
instead of talking about it
do it
behave like a philosopher
it says for example at a banquet
do not say how people ought to eat don't
be one of those busy bodies who comes
along and says you know the stoics would
tell us that we should have smaller
portions and here's here's a hint about
that if you take the plate and you make
the plate smaller the smaller portion
will look bigger by comparison people
don't want to hear that sort of thing
and they definitely don't want to hear
that some philosopher has this idea
if they do want to hear that sort of
thing it will be afterwards after you've
actually behaved like a philosopher
which means behaving like the kind of
person
who has something worth studying or or
learning from so
he goes on and he says you know don't
tell people how to eat eat as a man
wants
and don't worry about whether other
people are catching on to it or not
in most cases they're not going to
because most people aren't paying
attention most of the time right it's
very selective what they're doing and
when they do pay attention
perhaps half the time most people get
wrong what's actually going on this is
this is the human condition right
but
if you behave in the way that you ought
to in the way that your philosophical
principles say is a good way for you to
behave you can then display to other
people what philosophy leads to and then
if they ask you hey
why is it that i never see you pigging
out and taking you know extra helpings
and depriving other people of them at
the dinner table or
acting like a jerk in conversation he
said well uh that's because i've been
studying stoic philosophy people are way
more likely to
be interested in in stoic philosophy and
think that there's something there than
if they see you behaving like the same
like everybody else but talking the talk
about stoic philosophy when we can say
this about really any sort of
transformative uh spiritual or
philosophical practice
he goes on and he says
remember how socrates
so completely eliminated the thought of
ostentation
that people came to him when they wanted
him to introduce them to philosophers
and he used to bring them along socrates
was a philosopher if you read plato's
dialogues
you will see people saying to socrates
hey can you introduce me to this guy
because i hear he's a philosopher and
socrates yeah okay let's go talk with
him and then usually what ends up
happening in the dialogue is it turns
out that you see socrates really is the
philosopher and the other person isn't
but socrates doesn't come out and say oh
if you want a philosopher i'm your guy
right here don't bother with him he
doesn't do that at all he's humble
he's unassuming
he's willing to let people
see and make up their own mind he
doesn't have to tell them
how to behave
a stoic is not going to be a busybody a
stoic is not going to be somebody who is
constantly talking about stoicism unless
perhaps other people ask him to do so or
he's got a job like epictetus to teach
in a school where people can come
and study if they want or leave if they
want
so he says
if talk about some philosophical
principle does arise among lay people
what should you do
and how does that sort of thing happen
you know
if you think about our culture you can
click around on the internet and you'll
find all sorts of interesting magazines
some of them labeled philosophy this or
philosophical this and they'll be cool
articles and people like to read them
and post them on on their social media
and talk about them at dinner parties or
you know mention them here and there and
okay so there's like a
intellectual environment in which people
might in fact talk about philosophy
what should you do
what epictetus tells you he doesn't say
aha now here's your opening get in there
and start preaching stoicism
no he says
uh if if talk about some philosophic
principle arises among laymen keep
silence for the most part
why
well maybe you're not the one to
actually teach it to them maybe you
haven't fully worked it through
if that's the case
you're probably not going to be that
helpful to them certainly not as helpful
as you imagine that you're going to be
so what would be an example of this he
says there's a great danger you will
spew up immediately what you have not
digested
when we take in philosophy here's the
metaphor we're we're eating right we're
and then we have to digest it and we
have to make it part of who we are so
with stoicism
if we
don't walk the walk and we don't walk it
for quite a ways so that it becomes the
way in which we walk
and not just the direction that we're
hopefully heading towards
when we talk the talk it's going to be
extremely unconvincing to other people
understandably so
so he goes on and he says when a man
tells you that you know nothing and you
like socrates are not hurt then rest
assured you are making a beginning with
the business you've undertaken
if you can take other people telling you
yeah you don't really know much about
this stoic philosophy i know all about
it i i've read some some marcus aurelius
and some epictetus and some seneca and
clicked on some websites where people
are talking about that and go on to
these lectures and i bought myself some
books and et cetera et cetera et cetera
it's not hurting you for somebody else
to make all these claims
it might be true although probably not
because most most people who are serious
about stoicism
have read this and don't act like that
but it's not hurting you
it's not affecting you and your core
of who you are
as a matter of fact it's just making
them look a certain way
so he says
sheep do not bring their father to the
shepherds and show how much they've
eaten
going back to the digestion uh example
but that they digest their food within
them and on the outside produce wool and
milk
so what should you do with the people
who are not yet into philosophy or may
never be into philosophy
he says do you therefore make no display
to the layman of your philosophical
principles you don't need to talk about
this sort of thing with them
let them see the results which come from
these principles when digested so you
know to take a a very common example if
your friends and family
who know you who who've been with you
for for a long time
see you behaving in a different way
having more self-control
not lapsing into these negative
emotional states
and lashing out at other people or
withdrawing from other people
handling the difficulties that naturally
arise within social life and even our
workplaces and technology and pick
whatever else you like even the weather
handling those things well
rather than getting upset like you used
to
eventually they will ask you they'll say
what's what's different what's going on
here how come you're not as upset as you
used to be why are you behaving are you
after something and then you can then
you can say to them well there's these
philosophical principles um and you
don't even have to say i've been
studying stoicism you could say things
like
well you know there's some things that
are in our control and other things that
aren't in our control and i've really
been concentrating on the things that
are in my control to try to improve them
and not worrying about the things that
are outside of my control
notice you didn't have to say stoicism
at all in that but you're talking about
the principles of stoicism you do that
by invitation you might say
not by way of lecturing people not by
way of you know putting up a facade
about what a what a great philosopher or
what a great stoic or whatever else you
want to say spiritual practitioner that
that you are
because if you do that you're not going
to be convincing if you do show people
uh
you know to use this metaphor of the
sheep if you digest the stoicism and
then you you know show them your wool
show them what you've actually produced
that in fact will be convincing
[Music]
you